as luca auch direkter wieso ich stell
begrüßen stellen aber wir haben das ganz
wichtiges voll wasser wait for 47 den
sind beim spielen den das gerade
gestorben und kampf gegen krebs und
kämpfe und ich werde jetzt auf ihn
werden versuchen sie mal zu klatsch
hätten uns nicht behördlich lines oder
lena ein zweites mal zu klatschen weil
er wieder blieb wurde unter nicht mehr
wiederbelebt werden darf ja okay wir
geben
du kannst kämpft kämpft kämpft der plan
bekommt erstmal mein haus okay und ich
habe ihn zwar das wort ab also halte er
ob wir lagen uns auf 3 1 ich bin schon
drin eine frau warum mein gott was dir
zwei grad denken alter was die bürger
denken so ich bin noch aufs internet
standbild ok ok bin wo ich bin ich flieg
rad wieder nach hause mit meinem
electric stuff den arena wird
wiederbelebt metern doch der wird
wiederbelebt
ich weiß nicht wo ich bin ich weiß ich
wo ich bin ich weiß gar nicht wo ich bin
wo ist die stadt von hier aus alter
ehrlich ich komme dem papier ab 1 ich
komme mir zu dir ich komm zu mir ich
kommt zu dir ich kommt zu dir einig
sicherheit meine wichtigsten sachen und
dem nun schwert mit menschen machen
jetzt richtig action aber ich hab gar
nicht dass das problem gerade und capcom
erst mal zu mir ins haus kommt mir das
haus ein leck tricks kaputt so erwarte
ich muss jetzt alles weg tun um vorhaben
ich hab' ich will und werde ich habe
auch gerade richtig angst dass wir jetzt
die von simon gekühlt werden deswegen
muss den sonntag laut erstellen capcom
schon über hier ist die trial rüstung
besteht daran um einem schwert habe ich
doch nicht wo ist mein schwert da mein
schwert und irgendwas irgendwas
irgendwas ok ich hab keinen in meinem
haus man vor
so voll ist
nebenbei mit ich hab da hätten wir das
von einer dorf ist die verzaubert sollte
nein ist er nicht ich hab ne porsche
noch lohne das ohne witz komm schnell
doch er hatte keine chance ja wirklich
keine chance
marcel in denen statt fliegen
ich bin tot ich bin tot was floppt kein
feuer protection pack ich mein gott
fliegt vorsicht vor simon weg sieht man
nicht weg leute wir hatten die angst die
ganze zeit gilt und simon direkt die
sagten wenigstens er lässt uns eine
minute oder so damit wir uns sammeln
können aber nein man schreibt gg alter
wo mein gott ich bin so weit weg
geflogen
das kann ich ganz genau wie anleihen
verloren
oh mein gott ich bin so traurig gerade
das aber nicht gestorben
simon schreibt grad conny und ich glaube
der ist bei mir mitten in der nähe
ja ich habe angst
schapdetten teppich kann dich gerade
nicht retten alter ohne job
ich kann mich okay ich kann ich bin 1000
blöcke von 10.000.000 blöcke von der
stadt weg ich habe einfach electric
stuff klaren weg gegangen aber dicker
ich habe gesagt das ist keine gute idee
wenn wir darauf hey leute ihr müsst ihr
das vorstelle haben und gar den stream
vorbeigeschaut und ganz spekuliert
wenn man die ganze zeit spekuliert gehen
wollte ttc acht mal kommen wir gehen
rein schnetzeln einfach nur der hohe was
simon ist da der nähe der lässt uns
bestimmt zeitweilig habe ihn heute
morgen der anruf dass ich gestern meinem
trieben den server fast zum absturz
gebracht habe mit meiner mode fahren und
dann ja ich habe gar nicht aber alles
beim explodiert ist aber ich wusste
nicht dass nicht so wenig gar nichts
habe wie jetzt und dann ja conny was
hast du ja noch zwei tore und so und
gibt uns bestimmt zwei minuten zeit
da wollten wir eigentlich da mal rüber
reporten und attacke machen
die hat mir gar nichts gebracht die
lustig war ein tourist ja du warst
direkt dauern und meinem eine rüstung
ist jetzt weg danke kämpfen
die hälfte war auch sowie dienstag
scheiße auf mama ich hab gesagt dass es
keine gute idee denn jetzt raufen aber
er war so ne kurze wir wollten echt
überlegen war wir ja nur eine stunde
oder zwei stunden dann bist du aufnehmen
aber auf den arsch der welt
bis level dich nur kenia ich schreib
kann ich bin einfach jahre alle laster
bei electric staps weggeflogen
aber gegen simon war aktiver nackt im
chat ohne witz livestream du held hdl
ich wollte in hama plan der beste plan
aber er wollte unbedingt
wenn ich jetzt wieder da hat es aber
auch keine sachen dabei nicht wichtig
ist ja aber ich habe sie mal gesehen
steht hier noch um mich herum entsteht
an meinem grabstein ja deswegen ich kann
da jetzt nicht hin also ich würd nur
sterben auch wenn ich dich wieder
beleben würde das wird die nacht kennt
den mann alter noch mal ich habe noch
meine ganzen sachen das ist wichtig nur
zwei sachen von der sva witzig also ich
bin ja nicht gestorben nur ich bin jetzt
wieder die große pose weggeflogen nichts
zu tun
beide unvorbereitet und die haben jetzt
einmal ja schon alles wir dachten simon
es gerade im kampf mit kers okay wir
gehen jetzt eben hier
das gerade ist weder getötet hatte wurde
response und naja gut nicht titel screen
jetzt hab ich noch weniger als gar
nichts das ist schonmal fantastisch das
heißt ich darf glaube ich die nächsten
zehn folgen niemals mehr aufnehmen wenn
ein gegner durch die mit also man muss
aber sagen ich habe den krieg erklärt
und so wie es jetzt ausschaut haben bei
die erste schlacht verloren also die
eher hamburg verloren
es waren ja mal so einzelkämpfe wo dann
einzelne person getötet sind ich habe
zum beispiel auch gekriegt dna zu töten
dann hat jetzt allerdings simon halt kev
getötet ist es dann hin und her statt
geld mischt sich in die nahezu gar nicht
ein
aber ich glaube mit denen nämlich auch
irgendwie selten auch das ist ja
irgendwie habe ich mit statt geld noch
kein einziges mal aufgenommen also ich
weiß nicht 11 und ich sind auf
jedenfalls erstmal verbündete
kriegsbraut hier und wir werden auf
jeden fall demnächst richtig randale
machen wenn irgend wenn ich irgendwie
ein anderes von ihnen anderen stadt
online sehen werde
käfer die nächsten folgen wir versuchen
zusammen aufzunehmen was dann aber wie
gesagt pause machen ja hier muss die
folgen dieser stelle ben war eine sehr
kurze folge der plan war vielleicht in
einer theorie nicht perfekt
ausgearbeitet aber vielleicht hat es
jedoch das ein oder andere sieg und
ihren spaß wo wir viele waren also der
sache ist ja die hat sie wir uns
eigentlich geschafft und so schnell zu
töten
er hatte ja das ding ist man kommt ich
komme ja auch so schnell in die anderen
städte oder ich wäre also schnell
gekommen hätte ich mein glück gehabt
dann aber nur schnell über bord und dann
bin ich damit bei denen in der stadt und
dann hinfliegen und dann 30 sekunden
und ich dachte nein das meine ich nicht
nur wieder und so schnell down gekriegt
hat auch nicht da nur ich ja gar nichts
geholfen weil das ding ist aber auch nur
mit protection vertraut also gar nicht
ich glaube das war der fehler
er hatte gar keine verzauberung außer
seelen gebunden hat die hatte nur serien
gebunden deswegen habe ich auch
eigentlich weg gelegt meine scale am ort
jetzt auch nur protection und an
breaking drauf und zwar sogar meine drei
skelettteile besser ja deswegen das ist
jetzt nicht so die beste rüstung gewesen
die trägen jahren naja egal so ist das
halt so passiert ich bin kein schlechter
verlierer
deswegen wie gesagt ich bin jetzt an
dieser folge dieser stelle die folge
bleibt gerade wir sehen uns beim
nächsten beim masken bis dahin genießen
wollten mit conny als
gestern natürlich rohstoffen sind sich
nach lara gut ja die sache zur zeit dass
ich jetzt am arsch der welt bin ich weiß
wo sca nach hause gehen muss denn wenn
wir die nächste folge aufnehmen werden
wir denke ich mal erstmal dann so locker
ich will sagen wenn es nicht mal
aufnehmen wird bestimmt zu drei folgen
auf oder sohn werden uns den essbereich
wird auch land gleich ein bisschen mehr
und das auch gleich zur späteren stunde
okay ist jetzt gerade nicht in der folge
wie spätestens aber ich würde sagen so
nach deiner folge lassen dort zwei
stunden passieren
ja weil es das kannst du mich wieder
beleben
ja weil das nicht aufnehmen das kann ich
einmal noch machen dann weißt du ja
stimmt in deinen nächsten folge darfst
mich dann wieder belebt dann lobby nicht
erst eine natürlich geht das ich muss
halt da muss schon langsam zurück laufen
bis zum ende der folge
hier stimmt wie komme ich dann so
schnell zurück du musst du wieso eine
solo aufnehmen ich hab ja platzsperre
stern topspieler martin verknappt das
heißt die folge für dienst aber die ihr
müsst ihr den rückweg sein oder so
scheiße mann ich muss jetzt so viel
zurück laufen alter also ich bin gerade
bei neun minuten und ich bin circa zwei
minuten nicht einfach nur ich habe einen
kompletten electric stuff verbraucht
alter wichtig stumpf aus angst es gibt
kein anderes machen sollen du meintest
du und ich war auch ich hatte nur noch
mal bisher das bringt es gibt also
gesagt du bist tot und dann mit ihrem
solo modus drauf und dann naja aber er
war witzig wir haben einfach keine
chance mehr verbündete stadtwald im
rother wenn sinken krieg direkt in stadt
roth vor aber wir können echt froh sein
das sage ich jetzt mal nur so ein
bisschen passiert ist meinte auch sein
können dass ich dir alles möglich noch
gegeben hätte dafür noch ein bisschen
mehr zeit gehabt hätten uns mega
equipped hätten alle möglichen sachen
mitgenommen hätten dann wären einfach
gestorben hätten wären quasi statt rot
gewesen welche ja gar nicht
wiederbeleben können oder irgendwie
sowas nur simon steht das halt die ganze
zeit in ich möchte jetzt nicht dass
wegen dem stream cox und dem mir sagst
wurde ist oder so das wäre jetzt
irgendwie so langweilig entschieden aber
ich denke sie man steht einfach die
ganze zeit noch formal vor deinem grab
rum und ich werde ich habe jetzt ein
boot getrachtet ich werde jetzt
versuchen schon mal den rücktritt
anzugehen und ich würde einfach sagen
diese folge nehme ich jetzt noch mit
caps und mündlich auf die nächste werde
ich dann alleine aufnehmen und dann
wahrscheinlich zurückreisen und sonst
danach wird damit cap aufgenommen dann
werden wir uns mega heftig auf den krieg
vorbereitet
ja also wir werden uns dann also so
heftig wie sie mal werden wir
wahrscheinlich dann erstmal nicht sein
aber auf jeden fall wenn ihnen welche
anderen leute da irgendwie online sind
dass wir dann schon ein bisschen
mitmischen können ich werde mir jetzt
gerne wüsste wir müssen uns auf jeden
fall ich habe
ich habe 16 so cage und soul keeper die
mache ich mir aus dem monster falle weil
wir brauchen auf jeden fall der monster
falle alter ja das ding ist monster
falle war bei mir schon gut gesetzt der
fehler war deswegen ist so geleckt hat
dass die aus holz war ramos manchmal vor
dass sie haben auch mal verbrannt dann
sind ja alle ausgebrochen ja und ich
habe eigentlich schon alle ressourcen
dafür da auch die soll cages ich muss
wirklich nur einmal vielleicht 15
minuten bringen habe ich die wieder
fertig deswegen lädt er nicht am besten
wenn wir uns irgendwie so ein monster
falle machen würden aber dann irgendwie
im untergrund so dass da keiner was von
mitkriegt auch nicht leute von der
anderen stadt weil wenn ich das mal bei
simon oder gar oder so sehr diese mega
aufbauen zu gast in der stadt weil die
sich einfach teleport hier mit dem magic
mirror
ach so und dann gehen ja waren die mabb
falle also ich weiß das komme bei die am
verzögerungs tisch war aber das ding ist
ja egal auch wenn die im untergrund sind
sobald die unsere folgen gesehen haben
kennen die das jahr ab orten die sich
einfach rein mit dem rocker spot das
kann auch sein
ich sehe hier die ganze zeit auf solche
themen aber die sind alle schon
eingestürzt
obwohl ich so weit weg bin ja die habe
ich also ich habe übrigens schon wichtig
hohen radius also bei uns abgefallen
generell das ist mega heftig wie weit du
hier auch laufen ich habe ja für die mob
falle circa also damit insgesamt
bestimmt schon 100 dollar oder so
wegnehmen er stimmt schon 250 sportler
weg geflext das 250er bestimmt also
leipzig war
wie hast du damit getan einfach mit soul
keeper also mit dem haus da macht man
das ja rechtsklick dandini kaputt wenn
die passend sind aber ich habe häufig
mit links dann mit der kapsel
mitgenommen also im ybbstal keeper weiß
nicht genau ob das genau also das ist so
ein pinker schaaf sieht das so aus
ja wie woher hast du denn den kann man
sich kräften aus enstone never gone und
also never reck und kloster kann jetzt
übrigens denn die shader reinpacken
freunde war jetzt der kriegsverbrecher
erste folge etwas trotzdem neun minuten
ja weil du hast das lange wochen
loszulegen man jetzt regnet es hier auch
noch auch kacke natürlich schon auf den
problemlos gelaufen ich freue mich auch
schon darauf wie alle leute wieder
meinen denn hier passiert ihr lauft
einfach weg ja was hat mir damals machen
müssen sollen
mein gott ich habe versucht
ich war dort vielleicht wird jeder stein
hat versucht du bist anhalt gestorben
ich bin dann mal weg gelaufen eigentlich
hast du es schlauer gemacht was hätte
ich ein anderes ist nicht gesetzt und
ich habe mich für dich in das schwert
hineingeworfen somit der brust nach
vorne ja mit meiner rüstung
draufgekommen hast du eine rüstung
angezogen bis gestorben
das war das war sehr gebunden was du
tust mir teile der rüstung etwas von mir
die essenzen bekommen gar nichts
ich habe von der ein nicht von den nicks
bekommen hast du nicht genommen da nix
ich glaube ich habe nichts genommen als
weißt du wo ich gerade bin ich laufe und
ich bin auf einmal bei unserer stadt
fahre ich bin ja nicht so weit weg
geflogen
hast du mich dazu leben schnell weil ich
sehen ja nicht wo du bist im stream
also ja ja dazu hast du die eier
ich weiß nicht wenn da simon ist oder
sondern meine folge ist gleich vorbei
ich habe angst dass das simon das alter
das ich ja nicht aussagen als mein vater
sie waren ruhe in der nächsten folge
werde schon der stadt bis wir sicher
sind dass dort ab und später wurde das
wiederbeleben habe angst dass die man da
ist weil du jetzt stirbt dann können wir
später nicht aufnehmen gibt schon regeln
bezüglich auslaufen
ja weil ich eine angegriffen hat darf
für mich ausloggen
dann müsste nämlich ebenfalls erst wenn
du circa 100 blöcke weit weg bist
begegne ich nicht sichtlich verfolgt
dann bist du auf alt ansonsten sogar
lange sich beide gegenseitig 30-sieg und
nicht mehr angegriffen bist auch auf
eine ahnung ob ich bin eigentlich galt
also simon gibst du dich aus du nicht
lange lief mathurin ja ich bin ja auch
gerade einfach unterwegs ich bin zweiter
nähe von der stadt aber ich habe angst
dass jemand irgendwo ist könnt ihr zwar
im stream gucken ich will
eigentlich gar nicht ich möchte diese
und dadurch ich will auch gar nicht
gucken das macht ihr das rpg feeling
kaputt alle beschweren sich immer gegen
irgendwas wegen rpg fing aber wir müssen
das auch wirklich leben also ich will
auch gar nicht schulen da will ich auch
nicht haben ja gut freunde deswegen sind
wahrscheinlich ihr die ganzen turnier
schon geleert aber ich hab auch einfach
diesen recht darf so durch gesprengt
dann geht das schnell kaputt und hast
nicht die optimale ausbeute nicht ich
hab den ja auch gar nicht verzaubert
gehabt irgendwie das ist auch kacke
gewesen was ich noch mal kurz simon auf
dem handy an vielleicht daran erfolgende
aufnahme rangegangen nur anrufen und
sagen die gegner auf anfrage noch bei
einer stadt ist manchmal erwarte die
lungerer kurz an lautsprecher für dich
okay das war's ja perfekt
er begeht dann glaube ich auch nicht
ich kann sie mir auch bei ihm anrufen
hallöchen
ich wollte nur sagen sie
das hast du dir auch echt verdient was
fragt die marge weiter stream livestream
vorbei die oder wie spaß kampf tot ist
tot
achso alter hast das will man wenigstens
meinen turm gesehen die gefleckte war
ich habe gar nichts an rift du kannst
wieder drauf kommt aber ich will nicht
nochmal gekillt werde ich hab schon ab
level der bank
ich frage mich zu fahren habe ich mich
hörst du congo after wir haben jetzt
übelste angst diesen beiden akt
wir haben aber auch nicht nein frage ob
er mich tötet zu mir hat er nichts
gesagt so mir nix gesagt der villa der
wie pizza der will mich töten alter
bestimmt nicht so statt alter also
kämpft du kannst draufkommen ich darf
jetzt aber ich habe jetzt die folge
schon fertig also ich leite jetzt schon
weil sie haben wir glaube ich eine regel
dass man auch von einer gewissen zeit
wieder belebte müssen in folge setzt
auch zu ende meine folge setzt so
ähnlich wird jetzt eben beenden
ja genau dann macht es keinen sinn
einfach meiner nächsten folge noch
weiter dann würde ich sagen meine lieben
freunde ermittelt
diese partitur cobos hier damit ich bin
ja gerade an erfahrung sammeln um die
sachen verzaubern zu können und dann
würde ich sagen der nächsten folge
könnte dann theoretisch eigentlich doch
dabei sein oder
in der nächsten folge nicht also nächste
folge habe ich applaus spendet das ist
ja so weit wie möglich dabei sein
ja also nehme ich meine jetzt im spiel
dürfte nicht dabei sein da ist er
gestorben heißt also die uploads sperrte
es geht jetzt nur ging es nur darum mal
du musst mich jeder bleiben sonst darf
ich hat zwölf stunden lang nicht auf den
server darf ich auch nicht im voraus auf
märz um boetticher jetzt wieder bildet
ja freiheit dann würde ich sagen die
nächste folge ist bei mir noch alleine
allerdings in der übernächsten folge
kommt es dann dazu
dann werden wieder heftig mega viel
produktives machen um einfach gibt wir
müssen uns einfach kriegs fertigmachen
machen uns einfach richtig tricks fertig
und dann werden wir die anderen einfach
pisten ich weiß nicht wie man hat in 50
folgende produktives gemacht ich weiß
nicht ob das dann so gut klappen wird
aber ich hoffe es mal und dass wir
eventuell dann ein bisschen zwischen
paranoia bei denen machen können das
regal und sonst würde ich sagen wo bin
ich eigentlich gerade als stopps nach
links laufen bisschen kann auch nicht ob
ich immer verlaufen
aber dieser turm der sagt mir eigentlich
dass sie nach links laufen muss ich weiß
nicht eigentlich habe ich sogar noch ein
bisschen zeit kurz
dass sich soziales lenzen
ich glaube das nächste karlsons das
sperrgut alter wie samson pace so geil
gespielt
das nächste chaos in zombie simon
plattgemacht chinas gar nicht ich weiß
nicht wenn es nur ein spaß kampf war
dann haben die vielleicht beide nun
holzschwert genommen oder so
wahrscheinlich auch direkt im nahkampf
ohne gruß fliegen oder so nicht glaube
ich auch einfach nicht jetzt 80 oder so
ich habe jetzt hier noch ein bisschen
kloster mitgenommen
die schoko zehn minuten wir brauchen
eine folge zu ende bleibt meine freunde
nächsten folge ich habs jetzt oft genug
erklärt wir sehen uns dann morgen
alleine wieder
und dann hat werden kriegsvorbereitung
die profis wenns euch trotzdem gefallen
hat könnt ihr das video bewährten egal
ob positiv oder negativ ist mir egal
bis dann